we are taking your call 617 830 for 750
that's the number and anything you want
to talk about I'm glad to hear about it
Rachel's glad to hear about it Pat and
not so much but he'll he'll he'll listen
under protest uh name and town who's
joining me next the others from lack of
work monitored Virginia Frank our
Catholic and uh uh recovery expert from
Virginia Frank it's been awhile since
we've spoken to you what what's on your
mind today well the thing is I was a
specific you know I was um looking at
different things and about the upcoming
election and I thought maybe Jill Stein
might be an interesting alternative
what's going on but you basically leaned
toward voting for Hillary Clinton it
which is probably what I'm going to do
okay but I have concerns about it for
wall street connections more than
anything else who doesn't on on Twitter
which is definitely the most mcevoy ask
social medium out there I mean 140
characters chase short snarky things
right I throw things on there like um
one of the wall street banks for said of
Teddy Roosevelt we bought him but he
didn't skate bought and I I sort of
applied that to maybe but if that's all
I want to say on this lowers and keep up
the good work man all right we'll listen
Frank the right thing especially in
Virginia even though Trump has conceded
Virginia and pulled resources out of
there the right move is to vote for
Hillary Clinton because you just never
know and I think you're going in the
absolute right direction uh I've said
before there are a number of areas on
which I don't agree with jill stein but
more importantly I think her depth of
knowledge is just really not there on
most issues and I think she's also
completely unqualified to be running
anything so that's why I'm not voting
for Jill Stein Rachel and I know some in
our audience like that and some people
don't like it Frank seemed just sort of
open minded yeah I mean I definitely
agree with you on that that's also why
I'm not voting for Gary Johnson among
many other reasons uh in a dish
to the fact that most of his views are
completely anti progressive I'm sure as
a factor yeah that pretty much that's
good ok rancor always great to hear from
you Frank thank you so much ok try start
yep take care